N
NOVEMBER.
ON TO MY MONOLOGUE.
ON THIS SHOW I SPEAK THE TRUTH.
AMERICA HAS BECOME A POLICE
STATE.
WE ARE NO LONGER BECOMING A
POLICE STATE, THE POLICE STATE
IS HERE RIGHT NOW.
THE BELOW THED GOVERNMENT
INSTITUTIONS, THE FBI, THE DOJ
AND THE IRS ARE IMPOSING
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF CONTROL
ON YOU.
IT'S NOT AN ACCIDENT.
LET'S START WITH THE DISGRACEFUL
POLITICAL POWER GAMES.
WHEN THE RAID ON MAR-A-LAGO
FIRST HAPPENED I WAS THE FIRST
TO CALL OUT THE OVERREACH.
THIS IS SOME THIRD WORLD [BLEEP]
RIGHT HERE.
WE DON'T LIVE IN CUBA.
WE DON'T LIVE YOU CAN KIM
JONG-UN.
THE MANAGEMENT OF THE FBI HAS
SHREDDED ANY SHRED OR SLIVER OF
CREDIBILITY THIS AGENCY HAD
LEFT.
DAN: I GAVE THAT APPEARANCE ON
JESSE THE DAY THIS HAPPENED.
THEY ARE STILL CHEERING ON THESE
POLICE STATE TACTICS.
>> OH, MY GOD.
THE FBI RAIDED DONALD TRUMP'S
HOUSE IN MAR-A-LAGO.
TRUMP GOT BUSTED FOR TAKING WORK
HOME WITH HIM.
>> WE ARE REMINDED AGAIN THAT IN
AMERICA NO MAN IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> YESTERDAY WE ALL GOT THE
PRESIDENT WE WANTED.
FBI AGENTS RAIDED MAR-A-LAGO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
DAN: THEY LOVE THIS.
THIS IS THE DEFINITION OF THE
USEFUL IDIOT.
WHY ARE THEY OBJECTING TO A
SPECIAL MASTER TO REVIEW THE
DOCUMENTS?
WHAT ARE THEY HIDING?
IF THEY CAN DO IT TO TRUMP THEY
DOCKET TO ANYONE.
ONCE THEY GOT A LITTLE BIT OF
TASTE THEY BECAME DRUNK ON
POWER.
THE DOJ ISSUED 30 SUBPOENAS ON
TRUMP ASSOCIATES AND SEIZED THE
PHONES OF HIS ADVISERS,
INCLUDING MIKE LINDELL WHO SELLS
PILLOWS.
THE DOJ IS GOING TO SAVE
DEMOCRACY BY GOING AFTER BATH
AND BED PRODUCTS?
WHAT ABOUT THE SLIPPERS.
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE NOT TRYING
TO INTIMIDATE YOU?
YOU ARE WRONG.
WE ARE NOW A POLICE STATE.
I COULD FILL THIS ENTIRE
MONOLOGUE.
THIS IS SERIOUS.
HERE IS THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF
BLATANT OPEN POLICE STATE
TACTICS.
THIS IS THE "NEW YORK POST."
FACEBOOK SPIED ON PRIVATE
MESSAGES OF AMERICANS WHO
QUESTIONS THE AMERICAN ELECTION.
SOMEBODY AT FACEBOOK RED FLAGGED
THE SUPPOSEDLY SUBVERSIVE
MESSAGES AND TRANSMITTED THEM TO
THE DOMESTIC TERRORISM UNIT IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. WITHOUT A
SUBPOENA.
PRIVATE MESSAGING.
NOT PUBLIC STUFF.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND HOW DANGEROUS
THIS ABUSE OF POWER IS.
FACEBOOK SENT THEM ACCORDING TO
THE SOURCES REPORTING WITHOUT A
SUBPOENA TO THE DOMESTIC
OPERATIONLE -- DOMESTIC
TERRORISM UNIT.
WE NO LONGER LIVE IN A
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
THIS POWER GRAB HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR A LONG TIME.
REMEMBER ALEX BARON ON.
AFTER HIS VIEWS WESTERN
VINDICATED THEY ALLOWED HIM BACK
ON.
NOW HE LEARNED THAT WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS PRIVATELY PRESSURED
TWITTER TO KICK HIM OFF THE
PLATFORM.
THEN THE WHITE HOUSE CALLED FOR
EVEN MORE CENSORSHIP.
>> THERE ARE 12 PEOPLE PRODUCING
60% OF ANTI-VACCINE INFORMATION.
ALL OF THEM REMAIN ACTIVE ON
FACEBOOK.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE BAND ON ONE
PLATFORM AND NONE OTHERS FOR
PROVIDING MISINFORMATION.
DAN: THE WHITE HOUSE OPENLY
CALLS FOR CENSORSHIP OF FREE
SPEECH AND RESTRICT YOUR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T LIKE WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
ABOUT VACCINES.
THAT ONLY HAPPENS IN A POLICE
STATE WHICH YOU ARE NOW LIVING
IN.
PERHAPS THE SCARIEST PART OF
THIS WHOLE THING IS THE PUSH TO
CONTROL EVERY DOLLAR YOU MAKE
AND SPEND USING A CENTRALIZED
CURRENCY.
PEOPLE ARE PUSHING FOR IT, AND
IT'S A HORRENDOUS IDEA.
THE PANDEMIC PUT AMERICA ON THE
TOTALITARIAN FAST TRACK.
HERE IS THE GENERAL MANAGER FOR
THE BANK SAYING THE QUIET PARK
ABOUT THE DIGITAL CURRENCIES AND
ABSOLUTE CONTROL RIGHT OUT LOUD.
>> IT'S THE CENTER WILL HAVE
ABSOLUTE CONTROL ON THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT WILL
DETERMINE THE USE OF THAT
EXPRESSION AND WE'LL HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO ENFORCE THAT.
DAN: THE WHOLE ABSOLUTE CONTROL
THING.
IT'S WEIRD HOW THAT KEEPS COMING
UP.
YOU WANT TO SEND A DIGITAL
CAMPAIGN DONATION TO A MAGA
CANDIDATE?
THEY WILL JUST FREEZE YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT.
CANADA DID SOMETHING LIKE THAT
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
REMEMBER THE VACCINE PROTESTS
THAT HAPPENED.
AMERICA IS ALREADY A POLICE
STATE.
BUT HOW BAD CAN IT GET?
>> THE NATURE OF THE CDC, WHAT
IT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
ID HEARD ONE EUROPEAN CENTRAL
BANKER TELL ME WAY IT'S GOING TO
LOOK LIKE.
AND IT WOULD BE IMPLANTED UNDER
THE SKIN.
SO THAT IS THE PLAN.
THAT HAS OTHER IMPLICATIONS ON
TOP OF WHAT WE MENTIONED AND ON
TOP OF THE CONTROL ASPECT
BECAUSE THAT ENTERS YOUR BODY.
IT VIOLATES HUMAN DIGNITY AND
CAN BE THEN USED FOR IN TERMS OF
FUNCTIONALITY BEYOND THE
MONETARY TRANSACTION PURPOSES.
DAN: YOU CATCH THAT.
THE CONTRACTUAL BANK DIJ TELL
CURRENCY, THEY WANT TO PUT CHIPS
UNDER YOUR KIN.
I CAN'T VOUCH FOR WHAT THAT
ECONOMIST SAID.
HE'S A RESPECTED GUY.
IF HE'S RIGHT HE'S TALKING ABOUT
WHAT I HAVE BEEN WARNING YOU
ABOUT.
THE MANDATES WERE ABOUT
CONDITIONING YOU TO ALLOW
GOVERNMENT CONTROL OVER YOUR
BODILY SOVEREIGNTY.
AMERICA IS ALREADY A POLICE
STATE.
HOW DID WE GET HERE?
IT HAPPENS THE WAIT ALWAYS
HAPPENS.
IT HAPPENS SLOWLY, AND THEN IT'S
FAST.
THE 2016 ELECTIONS WERE SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT EXPOSED THE
POLICE STATE TACTICS OF THE
GOVERNMENT AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
AND THEY PAID OUR TAX DOLLARS
FOR RUSSIAN INFORMATION TO GET
INFORMATION ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
TO FRAME HIM FOR COLLUSION.
I SAID IT MONTHS AGO AND I WILL
SAY IT NOW.
WE ARE TURNING INTO A POLICE
STATE.
THE MISSTATE IS HERE.
YOU HAVE A CHANCE